it's just gonna be a good fun event
comic book but I think at first blush at
times visually you can you can meld them
a little bit too close but now the
bigger question is what makes them
different and their goal of this ain't
just sort of saying beneath the costume
what drives each one of these gentlemen
I've lived in both of those worlds for
10 years a piece so it's just easy it's
easy the best time I've had working in
comics is with thought once Greg said
he'd do it then it came the next phone
call which is hey what do you want to
drop and he said hey you know what these
quarter owls might be fun to do it boom
done the goal is to
make a mark with this book in in a one
shot there's lots of Great Moments the
first time you see like a dramatic shot
of our two main characters together Greg
and I know that we only get these
moments a handful of time in a long
career and when you see something that
you know brings you back I mean
everybody likes that ride and for the
newcomers it's just gonna be something
wow and cool
thank you
foreign